(upbeat music)
(brand sizzles)
- Here's a quick tip from someone we love.
- Hey, Drew, here is a design tip.
If you're stuck on how you
want your place to look,
think instead about how
you want it to feel.
Do you want your home office to be a place
that feels inspiring,
or your bedroom to be a
place that feels sexy?
Maybe you want your living
room to feel super relaxed.
So close your eyes,
and transport yourself to the
last time you felt that way.
The last time I felt truly relaxed,
I was at the beach.
So I'm gonna pull in
those beautiful blues,
those sandy hues.
I'm gonna bring in drift
woods and washed linen.
And I'm gonna take cues from that place
where I felt relaxed
to design a relaxed space in my home.
So let the feeling guide you.
- That's genius.
Why didn't I think of that?
(upbeat music)